[Musik]
ich bin darüber zu einem priester und
missionar keine gute journalisten 27
ich habe frieden dem land anzutreten
[Musik]
alle im feld kocht als wir ihn besuchen
auf dem herd steht eine suppe über die
genauen zutaten schweigt er sich aus
in jeder suppe muss ein geheimnis sein
belegte seine mutter zu sagen wenn man
es verrät verscheucht man alle guten
geister für natürlich dem wochenmarkt
bei aus verwendet immer fleisch gruppe
wiederum kräftig und stärke ihre nato
wettbewerb unserer klasse
damit baut stärker wird mutter praktisch
das ganze hätte kinderlos erwartet aber
weitere touristen denen die fahrer stark
bleiben
[Musik]
und
seine heimat sei die fantasie sagt im
feld er sei in aller welt zu hause wer
ihn verstehen wolle müsse wissen woher
er komme
in der marken entstehen
wie hätte man feldmann overtime konnte
ambri nicht im schnitt mit großfamilie
familien abgewählt und immer wieder
führt er sie doch gar nicht welche taten
des sturmes gibt und der stimmigen
august genau ist wird es nicht aber
risiken
ohnehin hat zeichnet dort genauso wie
südafrika fleisch wenn sie sich leicht
da kann man dann genauer gesagt habe ich
hier das buch klose ich besser machen
muss rose und seine mutter gut die weiße
pracht eigenes usa v
[Musik]
oder anrufe wie er von geburt aus heißt
ist das älteste von 13 kindern 1935
geboren ist er vier jahre alt als der
zweite weltkrieg ausbricht
sein vater der zur mobilmachung
einberufen
während sich die mutter um hof und
familie kümmert all dies mit so gut er
kann
das habe ihn mit stolz erfüllt erinnert
er sich
denn er sei schon als kind einer gewesen
der etwas konnte aber haben sich die
länder kamen in das café der heimat von
unterfranken twitter und sind auch
gespräche und noch da ist dann auch egal
nämlich für unfair glück und die honey
die belohnungen erklärt bibliothek kam
einfach nicht am tisch kam und dann klar
dass es bei bis zu gravieren biene zu
klar sein wenn man sie unter viel klasse
erhältlich
ich bin für die jugend in das neue
gebiet caprica
wenn aber die mission ist japan oder
china offen
die heide predige programm fertige
computer und vermittelt das ist ein ganz
anderes und sperrte sie das kleid auf ex
oriente lux das wort ich mit lothar
bisky liegt kommt aus dem osten
auch im gespräch für banker aus doch
musste sie trug ihre vorbehalte
nachricht quelle der kabbala die 1200
ferrari benötigte
der junge instinkt ist fasziniert von
fremden kulturen bleibt aber immer stark
verwurzelt in der landschaft seiner
herkunft wir sind dieser woche hinweg
wie oft schießt wenn man den afrika
musical sind und wenn zusätzlich zum
fenster können dann okay und ich
eigentlich nie dem napf gibt sie zu und
wir ein eigenartiger berg ist es
beherbergt ein baugleicher china und das
landschaft
[Musik]
besonders pünktlich vor dem großen
moment wenn sie die allmacht geworden
die ständigen kunde wir sind nur weil
die pläne für eine schiene und zudem
wandert also bauten land nicht
[Musik]
riesig freute mich packte mich
fasziniert nach der tradition geht der
elterlichen hof an den jüngsten sohn
während der älteste priester werden
sollte oder noch besser mit allen feld
folgt diesen wunsch er besucht das
gymnasium der missionsgesellschaft mw wo
er 1954 die matura machen
das ist eine vision festlegen das
geburtsdatum standen ist heute genauso
wie mussawi gestimmt um diese minute die
sturz autor schweizer waffen fällt ein
großes vorbild
doch in lambarene im westafrikanischen
gabun damals noch eine französische
kolonie erlebte er einen anderen
schweizer firma day begangen um das
weiße zurück das ist auch gar nicht
geben aber mal fertig dortmund der us
und der sich mit in das boot irgendwie
zusammenhängt
dabei könnte sagen die neckar schicke
noch kann man schon für hübschen friede
springer im feld verlässt schweizer
spital in lambarene fluchtartig wieder
zu hause tritt er in das mission seminar
schöne kein einfacher job gegeben
kritisch hinterfragt
er grüßt so und sogar die vag das heißt
sie war schließlich ein dem studiert t
online.de strato predigen oder nationale
statistische anfang an für die jungen
musiker auf st
also ich einen fleckigen hatte selber
glaube ich weiß es nicht
für sie gab es für mich erst stellt die
tradition für glaube tue dies aber der
glaube muss ständig geforscht werden
entrümpelt wäre und wie und fährt weiter
dass einige sachen of scotland hat das
echo oder das hat sie
[Musik]
nun
die heilige schrift sind so wenig
wichtig ist zimt sache um rio
aussortieren um ich war nur reflektieren
und um ihr leben
häufig bildet sich kaiser weise sind
über schichtet sie sind neben ein
landunter genannt übernahm genannt und
so ich dir glauben programmierer mahnte
klopp frau bei dem sie mit theologen
dass meine gibt mir mit dass ich
irgendwo in meiner flüchte ich auf
frischen geist
[Musik]
als jetzt noch theologisch krieg und das
rasche wende 4g dass gott mensch wurde
mich und um die der mönche in la paz auf
dem auto alles was ihr positive gedanken
zeugnis ich mensch wurde nicht das
monster sich seitlich mit dem nächsten
treffer und von dem ich nur über die
nächste treffer ich meine ich dir heute
abwehr stehen mit überzeugung das stört
dass anleger annehmen und zum guten
modell finden noch immer geld suchen und
die neue modell entscheidet mit rom die
hände fiel
die verbotenen nummer über walter
schalke
1961 wird allem fällt zum priester
geweiht und zum doktor ihren an die
päpstliche universität nach rom
geschickt
doch seine dissertation die
verzweigungen im buddhismus mit
abspaltungen im christentum vergleich
wird abgelehnt
er wird der ketzerei bezichtigt und
motor verlassen um die schande
absolventen schickt ihn dann
generaloberer zum weiterstudium die usa
[Musik]
1963 besteigt partner ihn fällt das
schiff nach new york
[Musik]
auf der überfahrt führt er die berühmte
washington rede von martin luther king
überfahrt nach amerika ich lege die
pflicht eine neue welt auch geistig die
frauenrechte bei haid starke da nicht
auf quali anderen augen sehen
das thema chemie
es ist die zeit des vietnamkrieges der
raumfahrt und der schwarzen
bürgerrechtsbewegung noch verbreitet
john f kennedy präsident der vereinigten
staaten
[Musik]
das nur das symbol rauch gefälle sind
und wie dinge ist die große katholische
kita st patricks capital ist die fähre
us-komiker bis jahrhundert aber
praktisch ganz neue welten stoff
[Musik]
nur nicht danach ob wir nicht
kreditausfällen und rechnet noch allem
versetzt ich schwarz
alle hätten die größte sicht ein rom
theologisch und da hoch sei dass sich
seit die wenigsten aber weitere posten
bedienen konnte der posten verwehren
verbindet wieder 100 über 20 strafpunkte
[Musik]
ahlen ist eines der zentren
afroamerikanischer kulturen aus dem
radio tönt der bebop als musikalische
antwort auf den bei weißen beliebten
zwingt gegenüber der kirche in der
partner im feld die messe liest trifft
sich die bürgerrechtsbewegung um martin
luther king
die bürgerin vecchi kommt mit martin
luther king ping ist sie erkältet
massive mit 12 berichten wichtig dass
gültigkeit
[Musik]
und er bringt uns gewissermaßen das
echterdinger corp
ein kleines stück bis zum schluss
einfach ruhig und solidarität
aber ich muss die chance nach
journalismus wo afrika panik
[Musik]
die us-amerikaner der hände und henkel
badezimmer das zeigen die unter deutlich
dass geschichte sich langsam langsam das
typische berlin umgegangen dass einer
schicht es richtig war und die
tatsächlich stört oder sie eigene
schwarze über sagte katrani kultivierte
dortige tun dass der grand prix meeting
in lausanne ein einziger neben der
premiere sehr kompetitiv sein aber bis
studium unterdorf aber was den
mittelstand oder mexiko
geschickt im feld zum prozess nach
südafrika an dem nelson mandela zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt wird
im feld wird vom prozess ausgeschlossen
als bekannt wird dass er zur
bürgerrechtsbewegung gehört das kostet
ihn auch sein priesteramt in new york
aus pater alois
er studierte journalismus in chicago und
findet ungewöhnliche wege sich
finanziell über wasser zu halten so
beredte den playboy verleger hugh hefner
in ethischen und religiösen fragen 1966
greift er im auftrag der washington post
vier monate nach südostasien um
hintergründe über den vietnamkrieg zu
recherchieren wer besucht hanoi saigon
nord japan und taiwan und interviews
[Musik]
um seinen vietnam aufenthalt ranken sich
heute geschichten im feld plädiert auf
das recht ungelöste rätsel und schatten
in deinem leben in vietnam sei alles
möglich geworden sagt er
weil die wirklichkeit untergegangen sei
1967 ist er wieder in der schweiz
von hier aus reist er als missionar nach
den ba bay um eine unabhängige dritte
stelle aufzubauen
bis zu seiner herzoperation im jahr 2002
reist er jedes jahr nach afrika
also das war ein stück siebelt
kritischen intensiv betrieben habe in
afrika gibt die wirklichkeit nicht unter
vielmehr eröffnet ihm der kontinent neue
realitäten der forscht studiert
vermittelt arbeitet als
entwicklungsexperte journalist tropen
abdomen prozent geschichtenerzählern er
publiziert über 50 bücher berichtete das
radio und fernsehen oft stiftet er
unruhe und gerät zwischen die fronten
für die einen ist er zu wenig katholisch
für die anderen zu spirituell zu
intellektuell oder zu einfach
vielen ermöglicht er einen neuen blick
auf afrika und hält das interesse am
kontinenten war unvoreingenommen immer
auf augenhöhe mit seinen bewohnern in
afrika wird er an seine eigene herkunft
erinnert weil im hinterland rio doce um
weiß gott das aus dass zögerlichkeit
kaum ist in die blöde zähne sind die
primitive auf die zivile und politische
reden wir haben verständnis von jeder
reise sagt alle im feld komme man anders
zurück nicht los die eigene person
sondern auch das daheim verändere sich
am nächsten schicht anbot fleisch nur
ein teil vom ganzen
ich freue mich wenn man das denn man
nimmt unter rot-schwarz verdienen also
ab bis zu der baum da braucht wurzeln
aber er ist oben und da zeigt sich und
erlaubt und mit euch sicher
interessanter ist da wie kann ich mein
auto bau meint aus einer probe mit
dieser baum in brand
die wandel sprache das wort ruth
seelische moderne begriff wurde das gut
geht so biedere wanddurchbruch und ich
früher thanner frankreich gehindert
hanni mieten und das hat mich begleitet
und zusätzlich trägt den titel gehört
über
das ist gar nicht das ist ein wichtiger
begriff dass ich immer nur ein teil aus
dem wir heraus also mussten vornherein
der blue war um zu mir
also mich also so wie diese frau und ich
ging nicht ohne dass wir das wir ist
zusammengesetzt aus vielen ist es ganz
wichtig ihr also in bantu denker
unterscheidet das zeigt auch ihre ganze
philosophie woran sie eben
er hinterließ das heißt du musst dich
immer orientierte stand der dachstuhl
des einzelne schließt sie aber nicht
davon isoliert ich würde sagen die
vitalität sie irgendwie individualität
denke ich eigentlich ein vergehen
[Musik]
ich wollte dass man afrika dieser arbeit
respektiert das oderbruch silber grund
wo denn dann man schätzt dass man nicht
einfach vier weckt uhr das genitiv oder
ob er womöglich und verbietet es ist
eigentlich dass pocher durch das alles
wurscht bei dir problem herz bin ich
glaub du sie noch um richtung noch
kultur
wohin seine völker stoff denn es gilt
crespo ankläger kultur als gsh religion
sg erfolglos honig musik hat und so
weiter
[Applaus]
[Musik]
und missionarisch rechte sowie aktiv
eingreifen kann das wieder band toni ist
einfach krank sie verblüffendes system
zu drängen
wir legen das die eigentlich der umfang
ist und gegen die festsetzung des
stammbaums sowohl ihr gewalttätiger wenn
die band gesprochen es ist was ich ganz
großen dass das nicht indirekt erwähnt
wird
[Musik]
die polka minimieren wir aber noch heute
lässt allenfalls gesundheit keine großen
reifen dazu aber er pflegt deine
weltweiten bekannt hatte daneben
arbeitet er an einer umfassenden
anthologie afrikanischer dichter
[Musik]
weiße männer auch im vorfeld wird die
sätze den ruf und die los um die familie
botschaft wo die tour aber durch das
dach über das schreiben aus optimaler
wetters sind aus zeichen und liegt vor
mir so
das habe ich ja faszinierend es geht zur
sache und die meisten erklärt das ist
rudi heißt sie hätte kein punkt mehr und
sie fast ihr gesamtes mystische
sonderlob
wieso zwar nicht realistisch aber wo
benötigt
[Musik]
hmm
immer wieder steht jemand vor seiner
türe um zu besuchen um einen ratschlag
zu bitten um ein bett oder ein paar
fragen
[Musik]
die druckhäuser ich bin ein onkel sich
hin ist das brücke und ich begann die
frau als deine beste mischung sony
weiter so kann ich bis heute nicht
gestorben das kommando hand aber über
die etikette trainerin
[Musik]
das ist rang verwies lammert auf das
event organisator sondern ich glaube
eigentlich nicht dass der körper sich
wenn du aufhörst aber alle 36 und
sichtbar und zudem sinkt weniger suite
steht nun aber mit dass es noch etwa
david kross damit belohnt das sind
absolute der anfang vom orchester wie
theologie gar nichts
jeder kann
[Musik]
weil er kann
wie aber kam
[Musik]